most schools have multicultural centers
my feeling is that we need to think of
an entire campus there's multicultural
center I am Nicholas B with reason TV
and today we're talking with Jim Doty
he's the president of Chapman University
located just south of LA in Orange
County he's been the president since
1991 Jim Doty thanks for talking to us
thanks net reason covers a lot about on
campus issues related to things like
free speech free expression at Chapman
and as you look at other universities
are things worse now than they were say
20 or 30 years ago in terms of people
being able to have open honest
discussions about things like race class
and gender I think so even if you talk
with people like Jerry Seinfeld
comedians they'll tell you the same
thing they have to be very careful about
where they do their thing where they do
their humor because of political
correctness and that of course is true
in higher education
unfortunately because higher education
should be the beacon of free expression
and free speech what's driving to move
towards ever increasing restrictions and
kind of looking at more and more refined
insults that need to be addressed so
when people talk about microaggressions
or something I mean is it coming is it
coming from students as it coming from
faculties are coming from outside
agitators I think it's a general symptom
of increasing victimization where people
feel that they're victims of some kind
of social stigma tation and as a result
you have to be very very sensitive so
it's increased sensitivity the part of
everyone and free speech is not about
being sensitive free speech is being
being having the courage of one's
convictions and belief and free
expression that one can say anything but
that's inconsistent with perhaps a
speaker that says something that hurts
someone's feelings
so it's this attitude that we have to be
much more sensitive to people's feelings
I think of that in the mean is led to it
there are I mean there are some good
sides to that right sure I mean you know
so that I'm sure we can all think of
exam
from when we were in college or even
five or ten years ago where you would
just say things without thinking about
those that we're incredibly hurtful
bullet be bullying yeah this idea that
bullying is something that these days is
people are sensitive to they certainly
weren't when I was right now I had a
speech impediment and when I was a kid
and was a victim of bullying but just
about every young kid was so how do we
find a balance how do you pull it back
to a healthy you know a healthy respect
for people's difference but also not one
that effectively shuts down every
conversation if it bothers any single
individual I really wouldn't work
towards a balance I don't think that
would be healthy I think that it
certainly has to tilt towards free
expression free speech we need to get
over being sensitive to this and having
our feelings hurt we would hope that
over time in in a community where you do
have open and free expression of ideas
and that's the most important thing most
important one of the most important
values in higher education then I think
a culture will develop where people will
will be more careful about what they say
but it's up to them not to others to
impose rules and restrictions on free
speech yet and now last fall at Chapman
you criticized a center that was going
to be organized along kind of racial and
ethnic line so talk about what happened
there and how it was resolved yeah I
think that was a situation where there's
free and open expression I think that's
a situation that will continue to be
debated and it was a an issue that I
think most universities contend with and
that is whether or not Chapman
University should have a multicultural
center and there were wonderful student
students very passionate and and and and
what would the Multicultural Center do a
multicultural center would be a facility
where different clubs and organizations
a Black Student Union for example
Hispanic Club those organizations that
deal with race ethnicity even even
gender and sexual orientation feeling
unsafe meeting anywhere else would meet
in in a center that would be for
focused on on their space needs for
example and so there's a good argument
to have it most schools they have
multicultural centers my feeling is that
we need to think of an entire campus as
a multicultural center and one of the
great values of a university campus is
the breadth of ethnicity and sexual
orientation and and racial origin and
rather than placing too much focus on
that we should have a focus and
concentration in fact that we're all
human beings and and and that should be
our emphasis you know you were you have
a PhD from the University of Chicago and
economics you know what's the value
what's your pitch as an economist for
the value of a liberal arts education
the undergraduates the the focus should
be on the liberal arts you can get a
major but the focus by far should be in
the liberal arts graduate school is is
the time when you can focus in a
particular area specialization a trade
if you will but higher education is all
about learning to think and and expand
one's mind and and have breadth of
knowledge economics I'm an economist
economics it one could argue is a
classic liberal arts because you learned
how to think many people don't even know
how one can use economics in a practical
way that's more theoretical so critical
thinking skills breadth of skills in
terms of quantitative reasoning these
are the skills that people need to be
successful and if most studies that show
the students who majored in the liberal
arts initially their salaries are lower
but then they come back and they're
actually higher so one does not give
away future earnings power by becoming a
liberal arts major more importantly a
liberal arts major gives an individual
the the the the skills the understanding
the appreciation for arts for beauty
that leads to enjoyment in life that
transcends one's financial returns a lot
of people talk about a higher education
bubble that you know this is a higher
education there's so much public money
free and reduced-price money and student
loans and Pell
etc this is the next big bubble to
explode like the housing bubble did do
you worry about that I do and what I do
worry about is that there there's a
trend in higher education or distance
learning online learning and movement
away from that that close
student-faculty relationship that I have
found most valuable in my own education
the fact that I was able to work with
people like Milton Friedman George
Stigler but I can think of my
undergraduates William Graham other
great economist that that close
interaction to people on a log is the
way George Stigler would put it that's
all you need you don't need bricks and
mortar usually to people working closely
together and and it's expensive so I'm
afraid that in a market system that's
focused on cost we're going to lose the
best part of what education higher
education should be all about okay well
we will leave it there thank you so much
Jim Doty for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie